>> YOUR TESTIMONY IS, BOB
MUELLER DID NOT KICK YOU OFF
BECAUSE OF A CONTEXT OF YOUR
TEXT BUT SOME APPEARANCE HE WAS
WORRIED ABOUT?
>> UP MY TESTIMONY, WHAT YOU
ASKED HIM WHAT I RESPONDED TO
WAS, HE KICKED ME OFF BECAUSE OF
MY BIAS.
I'M STATING TO YOU THAT IT'S NOT
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT HE KICKED
ME OFF BECAUSE OF ANY BIAS, IT
WAS DONE BECAUSE OF THE
APPEARANCE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO REPRESENT WHAT
YOU SAID ACCURATELY, THEN I WILL
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION BUT I DON'T
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID BEING
APPRECIATE, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW AN FBI INVESTIGATION.
AND IN ADDITION TO DISAPPOINTING
MY DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES, SOMEONE
WHO WAS INVESTIGATING RUSSIAN
COLLISION DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS
ANY THERE, THEY ARE, WHY WOULD
YOU BE CONCERNED, WHY WOULD YOU
NOT BE ECSTATIC THAT THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION WHY WOULD YOU NOT
BE CONCERNED?
>> Sean: THAT WAS MORE OF THE
FIREWORKS AT TODAY'S EXPLOSIVE
HOUSE HEARINGS WITH THE
DISGRACED FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK.
JOINING US NOW COME THE MENU
JUST SAW A COME HOUSE GOVERNMENT
AND OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
SOUTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN TREY
GOWDY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, WELCOME BACK TO
THE PROGRAM.
AT THE HEART OF THIS I THINK YOU
CAPTURED IT HERE CONGRESSMAN,
AND THAT IS A BIAS.
THIS MAN WAS IN THE FOREFRONT OF
EVERYTHING.
DO YOU BELIEVE, AS I DO, THAT
HILLARY CLINTON HAD A RIGGED
INVESTIGATION, THAT SHE VIOLATED
THE ESPIONAGE ACT?
IT WAS A BIG CASE OF OBSTRUCTION
WITH THE EMAILS AND DELETIONS
AND A BLEACH BIT.
DO YOU BELIEVE AS I BELIEVE THAT
IN FACT HE WENT AFTER TRUMP WITH
A VENGEANCE BECAUSE OF A
POLITICAL VIEW HE EXPRESSED
OFTEN?
>> LET'S TAKE TRUMP FIRST.
BEFORE YOU EVER BEGIN
INVESTIGATING ALLEGED COLLUSION,
HE ALREADY MADE UP HIS MIND THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE
DESTABILIZING FOR THE COUNTRY.
INTERVIEW THE FIRST PERSON IN
AUGUST.
HE SAID, WE WILL STOP IT.
WE NEED AN INSURANCE POLICY, AND
THEN HE BEGAN TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT ONE DAY AFTER BOB
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION BEGAN.
SO, PETER STRZOK HAS A LEVEL OF
BIAS THAT WOULD MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR EVERY PROSECUTOR
TO STAND IN FRONT OF A JURY AND
CONVICTING DONALD TRUMP BEFORE
THE INVESTIGATION BEGINS, HE'S
EXONERATING HILLARY CLINTON
100000000-0, THAT'S WHAT THE
VOTE OUGHT TO BE.
AND HE HADN'T INTERVIEWED HER
AND INTERVIEWED 30 OTHER
WITNESSES.
>> Sean: DID YOU BELIEVE THAT
HIS EXPLANATION WAS RELATED TO
NOT BELIEVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HIS EXPLANATION OR THE 30 ODD
SOME DEMOCRATS.
60 DEMOCRATS HAVE VOTED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH IMPEACHMENT ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND BOB MUELLER
HAD RELEASED HIS FIRST SINGLE
SOLITARY FINDING.
SO THEY HAVE ALREADY MADE UP
THEIR MINDS.
HE'S THE ONLY PERSON IN AMERICA
THAT DIDN'T THINK HE WAS BIASED.
THAT DOES NOT UNDERSTAND HOW
INCREDIBLY DETRIMENTAL THOSE
TEXTS ARE TO ANY KIND OF SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION.
SO LOOK, I SPENT TEN HOURS WITH
HIM TWO WEEKS AGO ABOUT AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TODAY.
HE JUST DOESN'T, HE THINKS WHAT
HIS PERSONAL OPINION IS ARE WHAT
THE REST OF US CALL BIAS.
>> I GUESS THAT IS WHERE THE
SIMILAR PEOPLE WHO GO TO
WALMART.
I HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO LIKE WALMART.
I LIKE KMART AND COSTCO AND
TARGET.
YOU CAN GET EVERYTHING YOU WANT
THERE.
IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY, YOU ARE
A PROSECUTOR AND YOU NEVER LOST
THE CASE.
AM I CORRECT IN THAT?
>> YES.
PEOPLE AND SOME GOOD COPS.
>> WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE HERE,
HILLARY CLINTON IS ALLOWED TO
TAKE THINGS THAT ARE SUBPOENAED
AND DELETE THEM.
USE BLEACH BIT ON THE HARD
DRIVES, BREAK UP THE SIM CARDS
AND, YOU CANNOT MISHANDLE OR
THINGS HAPPENED.
EARLY MAY AND THEY DIDN'T
INTERVIEW HER UNTIL JULY 2ND.
AND THAT TO ME, DO WE HAVE EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW?
DO WE HAVE EQUAL APPLICATION OF
OUR LAWS?
>> AND THAT'S WHAT FRUSTRATES
PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT FRUSTRATES YOUR VOTE
VIEWERS WHO WONDER, WILL THAT
HAPPEN TO ME, TOO?
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI AND
ANNOUNCE MY INNOCENCE BEFORE 20
SOME ODD INTERVIEWS HAVE BEEN
DONE.
THEY WERE REALLY CLEAR WHEN THEY
WENT INTO HER INTERVIEW, SHE'S
NOT GOING TO BE CHARGED WITH
INFORMATION WAS NEVER IN
JEOPARDY, EVEN FROM BEFORE THEY
INTERVIEWED HER.
I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD LIKE
THAT DEAL, I THINK THE FBI MAY
COME TALK TO ME AND THE ONLY
THING I HAVE TO DO IS TELL THE
TRUTH.
AND ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS TELL
THE TRUTH AND YOU CAN GET OUT OF
AND THAT WILL STOP HIM FROM EVER
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
AND, THEY ALSO HAD A CHANCE TO
QUESTION PETER STRZOK TODAY.
WHEN THEY CALLED -- THEY ASKED
THE PHI'S OBVIOUS QUESTIONS, I
CALLED THIS SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE
AND POWER SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
WAS PETER STRZOK AND OTHERS, AND
THEY IMPACT AN AMERICAN ELECTION
IN A WAY THAT THEY SAW FIT TO
HURT ONE CANDIDATE AND HELP
ANOTHER.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
>> A POLITICIZATION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THE END OF
US.
IF WE BEGIN TO VIEW THAT
WHERE WE ARE, THEN WE ARE
FINISHED AS A REPUBLIC.
I'M PROUD TO BE ON THE HOUSE
PFIZER ABUSE.
AND WE'VE MADE GOOD PROGRESS ON
WHAT WENT INTO THAT PFIZER
APPLICATION.
SO I KNOW THIS.
I KNOW THERE WERE LOTS OF THINGS
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THAT
APPLICATION THAT WAS PRESENTED
TO THE JUDGE THAT WERE NOT, AND
INTERVIEWED 30 FACT WITNESSES.
SO IF THAT IS NOT A DICHOTOMY
WHERE WE WILL WITHHOLD
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION IN THIS
CASE AND NOT WITHHOLD ANY
PROSPECT OF PROSECUTION IN THAT
CASE, I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYONE
CANNOT BE LEFT WITH THE
CONCLUSION THAT IF YOUR NAME IS
NAME IS JONES OR SMITH.
>> Sean: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
CONGRESSMAN IS REALLY SCARY TO
ME AND IT SHOULD FRIGHTEN EVERY
AMERICAN.
LET ME ASK YOU ONE LAST
QUESTION, WHAT NOW?
I THINK THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE FOR OBSTRUCTION
AND THE ESPIONAGE ACT AND A
NUMBER OF STATUTES THAT WE LAID
OUT HERE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO HER AND WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THE EXONERATION
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION TO
IMPACT THE PRESIDENTIAL
JUDGES TO GET WARRANTS TO SPY ON
AMERICANS AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE REPRESENTATIVES.
>> THIS IS WHERE I GET MYSELF IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE ALL OF THE
PRINCIPAL DECISION-MAKERS NOW
ROD ROSENSTEIN, CHRIS WRAY.
IT'S NO LONGER LORETTA LYNCH AND
ERIC HOLDER AND JIM COMEY.
IT'S OUR FOLKS.
IF THEY HAD SYSTEMIC ABUSE OR
POTENTIAL CRIMINALITY, THEY HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO PROSECUTE IT.
MY FEAR IS WHEN YOU HAVE THE
HEAD OF THE FBI STAND UP IN
FRONT OF THE ENTIRE WORLD AND
EXONERATE HER THE WAY JIM COMEY
DATA, I DON'T KNOW A PROSECUTOR
SO OUR OPPORTUNITY TO FIND OUT
WHETHER OR NOT SHE VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, I THINK JIM
COMEY -- THEY RUINED IT BY NOT
INTERVIEWING HER SERIOUSLY.
THEN THEY RUINED IT BY THAT
UNPRECEDENTED PRESS CONFERENCE.
SO WE WILL NEVER KNOW THE ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION.